so here you have the mom and the
daughter right there and then you have
them here with kind of a traveling party
same thing looks like they're out on a a
hunt and then they encounter a werewolf
maybe maybe she was bitten between this
one and this one and we don't see it and
then right here
it looks like he has just gotten some
bad news and then here's the crazy part
guys if you get close and you cast lumos
lumos
look at that
look at that she moves behind the tent
look at her look at that now she's
crying
oh that one's crazy then we go back to
this one lumos
and again let me go right here
and now she's watching them and then
probably the saddest one of all
or transformation is now complete